y llegamos directo a eeuu porque hoy
habrá votaciones primarias en cinco
estados salvamos entonces a nuestra
corresponsal en nueva york que mamen
salam amen la saludo muy buen día le
preguntó que votan en qué estados votan
este martes y además a que deciden
muy buenos días a 15 estados van a tener
votaciones primarias elecciones
primarias en este martes missouri donde
el político republicano candidato
republicano que abandonó la política por
varios escándalos entre ellos no seguir
las reglas electorales o una relación
extramatrimonial vuelve otra vez en el
lado demócrata tenemos a un veterano de
infantería y a una empresaria que se
sufraga ella misma su campaña en
michigan en una contienda entre
candidatos republicanos donde hay entre
ellos uno de los acusados en el ataque
al capitolio en arizona también la
mayoría de candidatos republicanos
defienden que a tramp le robaron las
elecciones algo que también vemos en
washington y en kansas raúl también se
va a llevar a cabo una votación muy
importante una votación a una enmienda
con una enmienda a la constitución
estatal sobre prohibir o no el aborto
claro precisamente dónde mohsén lo que
se va a votar sobre el derecho al aborto
en kansas a mamá en que está en juego
hoy al respecto
sí como sabéis cuando el tribunal
supremo de este país derogó el derecho
al aborto el dejo en manos de los
estados esta decisión pues bien esto es
precisamente lo que se va a votar en
kansas ahora mismo para que os hagáis
una idea del estado de kansas permite
abortar hasta las 20 semanas de
fertilización con un periodo de
pensamiento de recapacitar sobre la idea
de 24 horas pues bien ahora mismo lo que
van a hacer es votar a una sentencia que
hay del 2019 que dice que el aborto es
un derecho constitucional defendido por
la constitución estatal de salir
adelante que significaría pues que se
deroga este derecho y quedaría en manos
de los representantes del pueblo la
decisión sobre el aborto en kansas
debemos recordar que estos
representantes son en su mayoría
republicanos y ya han manifestado su
deseo de prohibir el aborto se trata de
la primera votación popular en 50 años
sobre este caso y la primera después de
la decisión del tribunal supremo así que
va a ser un termómetro en todo el país